What do you know about Velocity? Can you tell
me what Velocity is in terms of distance and time?
[pause]
Velocity is the distance covered in given
amount of time. We are aware that Velocity
is a vector quantity and is "direction aware".
It’s speed with direction. What about the
standard unit for Velocity?
[pause]
The standard unit for velocity is “meters per second”.
We have also learned that “CHANGE in velocity”
is called Acceleration… and the standard
unit for Acceleration is “meters per second squared”.
It is the measure of the CHANGE IN VELOCITY.
So an object moving in a straight
line at a constant speed has ZERO acceleration.
Now what we will see is the relation between
all these when an object moves along a straight
line with UNIFORM acceleration.
These are three important equations we come
across in Physics when we learn about motion.
V = U + AT
S = UT + one half AT squared
2AS = V squared – U squared
We will use U to denote initial velocity,
V to denote final velocity… A for acceleration,
T for time and S for displacement or distance…
Together these three are called the “EQUATIONS
OF MOTION”.
So when we are provided with certain data
and we have to find the missing information,
it is very easy to calculate the answer using
these three equations.
These equations may look very daunting at
first, but don’t worry about it, the next
few tutorials will make it very easy. We will
use graphs to derive them and that would help
make it very clear and simple. What we will
also see is how Physics, Mathematics and Geometry
are linked and the importance of being well
versed in all fields.
Before we start deriving these equations,
you should also be familiar with the terms
Velocity, Acceleration and Uniform Motion.
These form the initial part of this series
of tutorials and should be referred to whenever
the need arises.